o olá eu sou eliane maio são maringaense
eu adoro contar essa parte assim mas já
nossa cidade tem 73 anos eu tenho 59
anos então adoro contar que quantos anos
se maringá tinha 14 anos de idade essa
faz muito engraçada porque maringá
estava no auge da minardi então então
tava me esperando eu significa dizer que
eu conheço bastante da nossa história
então maringá é uma cidade de ouvir a
aoi e nessa cidade eu fiz toda a minha
história de vida meu pai minha mãe
casarão aqui em maringá de deus 78 anos
de idade ainda e quando eles vieram um
pouco os estudos são pessoas que não
tinham estudos da época meu pai gente
assistiu vou estudar minha mãe
e pagamos primeira filha era só pronta
para casar vida essa e aí eles deixaram
para gente que a gente tem que ser de
melhor que era isso que a gente foi
muito bom pois qual foi isso tudo que
eles oportunizar o brasil em maringá
tinha duas escolas particulares colégio
santa cruz de freiras espanholas lá na
praça sério e o colégio santo inácio
nascido operário um colégio de freiras
alemãs escolheram esse colégio das
freiras alimentos colégio santo inácio
eu estudei do mapa três ao terceirão
ficar nessa escola é rígida época da
ditadura né eu não percebi as questões
de gênero que vai diferenciado mas
gostava muito de estudar por lá grupo de
amigos de amigos e nos se inverte a
gente era obrigada a escolher um curso
técnico em
e o rosto eu escolhi foi análises
críticas estavam nas simpático achava
que vai de vestibular de química não
hein e terminei o curso então 1988 eu
esse né foi fazer o vestibular para a
farmácia viu que foi aprovado com a
minha grande alegria eu quero um curso
mais concorrido na oi e aí fazer a minha
matrícula creche não eu fiquei mais
velha fazer psicologia em são paulo eu
achava a coisa mais linda que tem 78 79
abrir um curso de psicologia na way o
primeiro vestibular eu pensei eu farei
brasil vai eu vejo eu disse eu aceito
também
a psicologia da oi maringá e foi
chegando a época da matrícula eu tinha
que escolher isso viu que sabe ou
psicologia acho que o coração falou mais
do que falou a razão porque não tinha e
eu acabei então entramos na metade do
ano de 1979 semestre era semestral é
entramos em 40 pessoas menino 39
mulheres questões de gênero já então eu
acabei fazendo nossos quero cinco anos e
cinco anos e meio porque eu vivi oito
graves dentro da oi nossa sétima formam
que nunca reprovamos nunca tiveram
dificuldade de seguir concurso porém na
coleção de graus 1118 pelas greves que
digita aqui o quarto ano a gente tira
a psicologia licenciatura e bacharelado
hoje só da série lá eu não queria te
iludir bacharel em psicologia que a
gente faz qualquer coisa que esse tipo
eu queria tipo de formação de psicólogo
e aí greve de nossa nossa certo não
tínhamos mensagens na oi tô procurando
emprego pertinho da minha casa conseguir
numa escola particular como estagiário
em psicologia escolar a minha alegria
era muito grande mas eu nem imaginava
que vai psicólogo escolar fizer porque
eu não tinha tido estágio que eu não
tinha tido ainda nada que mereça fui
alguém pedir para ser estagiário aceitar
mensagem mas tá o ingresso na linda
pedagoga coordenadora que estava lá o ar
infelizmente quando voltarmos seu estado
será que seria escola pública e lá e
privado você pode fazer mas vai ter que
essa outra supervisora na
e não tinha ninguém maria eu tava indo
embora uma linda professora da minha
linda até hoje ela me chamou e disse
pode aceitar está no código eu não tirei
contigo retrovisor previsões será de
graça o motivo o que você seus olhos tão
brilhantes que você ser a primeira
psicólogo escolar de maringá e hoje hoje
eu penso que eu fiquei museu e as
meninas vem entrevistar faz psicologia
você primeiro psicólogo 37 anos mas eu
acho história inclusive comecei está eu
não sabia fazer nada na área da
psicologia escolar eu nem conheci o
ambiente escolar não tinha experiência
não fiz magistério né mas você me
ajudava a equipa era muito legal eu já
fazia uma primeira especialização
especializações essa foi uma já fazer
psicodrama tem uma abordagem
você pode utilizar uma fita guga teve
uma ideia feliz depois eu vi que era
isso aí eu vou fazer grupos
psicodramáticos de meninos fazer uma
bagunça só moleque como se meninas não
quiserem eu adorei montar porque adora
uma bagunça acho que a bagunça que
encontra nos ensinar e os meninos
ensinavam que eles eram disciplinados
pela forma que fizeram criados com
baixinhos machistas e eu fui começando a
compreender no mês dois meses essa
dinâmica mais uma professora me chama na
falta professoras led para o menininho
de 8 anos da sala dela segundo aí para
que ele participasse do grupo ele mas
professor o que ele sai ele não fazer
bagunça era extremamente tímido como ela
professor ela pôs a mão na boca de sete
ele não
o nome daquele lugar lugar
eu te quero bem mas ela não conseguia
falar mais não viu isso há 37 anos foi
observado que tem uma hora aula na sala
é porque eu eles sabiam que eu fazia
escutava as crianças suas casas eo moral
o que você acha de mim é trinca-ferro
atender uma oral o menino de 8 anos para
se masturbando exageradamente aquilo me
assustou demais não era uma ocasional
foi mão tira a mão daí eu fui para minha
sala pedindo para nunca mais olhar para
mim hora marcada de previsão a
professora foi lá eles que ela chegou
ela disse que daí que que você vai fazer
nada para você tá na minha ignorante os
três motivos
e eu nunca tive educação sexual do meu
pai da minha mãe olhando nos seus olhos
eu não sei você se tiver eu não sei
aliás a branca para sustentar
assistência lá atrás como é que aprender
sobre sexo não tinha nem como segundo o
professor eu nunca estudei no curso de
psicologia da uem primeiro assunto só
como fazer um menininho parar de se
masturbar nem hoje em dia é isso
ensinado aí terceiro professora não
tenho um filho ou filha mas eu ajo pode
deixar conversei com as coisas horas
temos chamar a mãe amanhã não sabemos
que fazer veio a mãe muito quieta calada
só o pai era viajante representante
comercial na quinta de manhã eu não
conseguia dizer para ela que o menino
não tirava mal dele no final do pacu
morrendo de vergonha disse eu disse
mainha que ele não tira a mão do picuí
ela ficou muito assustada diz que em
casa
a bateria e na hora de dar tchau e pedir
para dar banho no menino que eu pensei
banho no de quem sabe diálogo né eles
que a sua mãe foi embora e marcou o
último horário na sexta de manhã para o
marido sexta de manhã 7:30 da manhã
estava na porta e fran eu tive que
atender ela de emergência e ela disse
ele não fui dar banho nele ele fez
escândalo na hora que eu fiz esse short
é certinho a porquinha disse que tava
toda suja de sangue porque o meu pai que
eu veio nome para o meu filho né tu mora
na casa da frente tá tentando estuprar
now no rio eu confesso que eu nunca
tinha escutado isso há 37 anos que meu
avô para assunto lavou que cuidava de
ler todas as casas para mim trabalhar
aí ela pediu para mim você conta
primeiro abrir eu disse eu conto e fazer
usar o seu pai na vara da família não tá
conselho tutelar ela foi embora e eu
fiquei muito as nove horas da manhã se a
mãe me liga e diz assim não precisa mais
se eu escutei meu marido chegou antes
descobriu tentou matar meu pai que fugiu
nós vamos embora da cidade de maringá eu
prometi naquele dia que eu estudar
sexualidade não sei como onde ninguém
ensinava eu me formei em 1984 fiz mais
quatro especializações cinco fiz
mestrado em psicologia doutorado em
educação escolar dois pontos doutorados
na espanha um aqui no brasil e acho que
não sei muita coisa não porque é que
eles tudo tanto as temáticas de gênero e
sexualidade em cinco razões eu espero
que você pensa em sobre ela a primeira é
já é a quinta especialização sexual
terapeuta sexual então eu digo que todo
mundo tem direito ao prazer sexual o que
é preciso só não sei o que é
eu moro a você que só que a gente tem a
pele mas o principal é o sério isso aqui
não tiver legal daqui para baixo nada
funcione só que todo mundo tenha direito
a trazer sexual com próprias escolhas
sem sofrer nenhum tipo de violência
segundo o seu mais justo contra qualquer
tipo de violência sexual contra crianças
e exploração sexual e adolescente eu
conheço muitas histórias de violência
sexual e assim mas pedem para escrever
um livro eu tenho muito eu digo que eu
não posso porque a gente já fazem as
pessoas sofrerem então a criança tem
educada sexualmente ela vai saber se
proteger contra quaisquer tipos de
violência terceiro vão ela de resultado
de sexual
oi madrinha 2014 maringá dá para vestir
pensa na alegria de poder estar junto às
pessoas que gostam de gente subir no
trio elétrico estava me sentindo a gente
sangalo né voz de ivete beleza dinheiro
e eu falei um monte de cima do caminhão
nada sofreu gente eu sou essa mesma
mulher gosta de homem sou eu mas estava
lá e falei um monte sobre a alegria da
diversidade sexual o que gostar de gente
não tem explicação seresta e longo a
sexual é gostar ou ter o respeito que
lisboa é uma luta pela diversidade
sexual violento feminismo eu estudo
muito mesmo tem que estudar bastante
feminismo negro mas mas para eu
compreender ou não como pessoa amiga
para eu acolher o que é dito divulgação
oi e a quinta razão quaisquer tipos de
violência de gênero então para quê que a
gente precisa trabalhar tanto as
questões de gênero e sexualidade no
sentido de que uma pessoa ela estão
cultural ela é econômica é uma
construção política ela não é o sexo
biológico que diz que imagine itália
pênis veralmar nas genitálias usa terá
uma cerveja não você não deveria ter
diferença de gênero é uma construção
cultural que no útero quando você sabe
que é uma menina se diz pronto vai ser
uma princesa você sabe que é um menino
vez pronto pessoais culturais quando a
gente põe enxoval rosa na menina não tem
explicação científica enxoval azul
menino que não tem explicação científica
e
o que é equação no hospital já ganhasse
menino brinquinho onde é devida
explicação para colocar o brinco na
família a gente não escolhe isso que a
textura ou não na orelha que os
brinquedos panelinha vassourinha
tanquinho cozinha da vaca carrinho de
bebê bonequinha tudo para o espaço
privado ao contrário do espaço público
ea gente espaço e assim se perpetua a
educação mostre para o óbito ea educação
sexista bastante violência contra mulher
e no brasil temos duas leis lei maria da
penha ea deixei no esse vídeo para nos
protegermos por sermos mulheres por
educação machista se a gente educar uma
criança na questão de gênero desde a
escola educação infantil essa criança
vai ser empoderado vai criar uma criança
martins homem ou mulher só o que então a
gente precisa fazer mexer repense mas
você já reproduziram as atitudes
machistas você já fizeram na história de
vida eu acho que a gente precisa mudar
esse mundo eu vou ensinar de exame com
uma frase que às vezes uma palestra um
homem com um professor um diretor de
escola ele disse assim vocês oração que
está errado em não senhor eu adoro gente
que gosta de gente ponto final como eles
foram tirados senhor eu adoro gente que
gosta de
e não importa o buraco tem como que sim
porque ela vem falar comigo eu sou
psicóloga gente então ele na cloud muito
e eu espero que vocês entrem no matinho
agora gente que gosta de gente o mundo
anda precisando disso muito obrigado